you are officially off the market oh
I've been off the market since I met
Demi that's for sure the case but it's
exciting you know it's exciting to find
that person that you're going to spend
the rest of your life with and that you
know is that right person to Tim Tebo
and Demi Lee Nell Peters tie the knot in
a gorgeous sunset ceremony at LA Paris
estate in Cape Town South Africa on
January 20th
et caught up with the newly weds earlier
this month at the IMG Academy in Florida
what was some sort of like a personal
element that was extremely important to
you to have as part of this wedding
ceremony
I'm just Anna her and her family and her
culture her heritage where she's from
and to have that represented and I think
it's been pretty fun blending the two
you know the two cultures from
definitely an an American Southern
culture and then also you know South
African and there's so many fun things
about both but to be able to blend it
but to never take anything away from
where she's from or her love for a
country or her people and to be able to
to honor that that's wonderful and what
about for her what was something that
was really important for her to put into
play for y'all's wedding I think it was
the the the time to celebrate and the
the moments that wasn't rushed by with
all of our friends and our family and
our loved ones to really embrace that
and and set aside the right time to get
to know everyone that might be new for
her or to be able to spend that that
one-on-one time with family and friends
to to embrace the process not rush the
process Tebow confirmed the two were
dating in summer 2018
he proposed last January
[Music]